STEVE BAZYL: Hey, everyone.
Thank you for joining today for
another Google Developers
Live session on Google Drive.
Today we're going to talk about,
how to use Service
Accounts with Google Drive.
For those who aren't familiar
with Service Accounts, this is
a special mode for OAuth 2.0
that is really designed to
allow applications to
act as themselves.
Typically when we're using
OAuth with the Drive API,
we're building applications that
are acting on behalf of
the user and accessing the
user's data on their behalf.
And that requires a particular
flow around what we call
"three-legged OAuth," where
there's this exchange, a
series of re-directs, in order
for the user to delegate that
access to your application.
With service accounts, we're
basically removing the user
from that equation, and allowing
the application to
use its own credentials,
and act on data.
In the case of Drive, there's
really two use cases that this
becomes very useful for.
One, is--
in cases where you actually just
want to build an app that
stores data in Drive, but it can
continue to own that data.
It can still share files it
creates in Drive with users.
It can use some of the advanced
features in the SDK
such as document conversion,
OCR, image recognition, and
Goggles, but doing this all in
the context of owning the data
itself, and not acting
on behalf of a user.
There's a second use case,
which is particularly
important for Google Apps for
Business customers, which is
user impersonation.
And we can use the Service
Accounts functionality in
OAuth to allow an application
to act on behalf of users
within a domain, but without
involving them directly in the
authorization.
And we'll actually go
through both of
those with some samples.
For those who are curious about
how service accounts
work, you can find information
at developers.googl
e.com/account/do
cs/oauth2serviceaccount.
I actually have the
page up here.
This page actually goes a lot
into the particular protocol--
the mechanism-- which
is it's an assertion
profile that uses JWTs.
You'll see those are j-w-t,
pronounced "jawt." And it's
basically a small bit of JSON,
it's Base64 encoded, digitally
signed, and then transmitted
over.
It's a lot simpler than a lot
of the other assertion
protocols that been around
for while-- things like
[? SML-- ?]
[? so ?]
[? it's ?] really simple, very
lightweight, and easy to implement.
Again, the information
on here is really for
building it for yourself.
The good thing is most of our
client libraries actually have
this functionality built in.
It's very easy to use.
And for the demos that I'm going
to do, I'm going to be
using the Ruby Client since
that happens to be
the one I work on.
But again, you can find the same
functionality, similar
code in Java, Python, PHP.
And I think most of
the libraries now
have this built in.
So the first thing you really
have to do when you're using
Service Accounts is you have to
create credentials for your
application.
I'm going to switch over
to the API's console.
And here, I actually already
went through the steps of
creating it.
And you can see here, we have
a service account with a
client ID and email address.
And this actually downloads
a new private key when you
create this.
Actually just going to create
another one here.
We can have as many of
these as we want.
But it's really simple.
Create client ID, you select a
service account, and create--
that's going to generate
a key pair--
you can download this.
And we'll get a PKCS12 file.
You do need to make note
of the [? secret. ?]
Right now these are not password
projected-- well they
are password protected, but
it's the same password for
every file.
So you do need to take care of
protecting your private key
once you get it.
Also you cannot download
it again.
If you do lose that file, you
do need to regenerate it so
that you have a new one
for your application.
But we created another one.
I' m just going to use the first
one that I had over here
and switch over to our little
sample application.
For those who have gone through
the quickstarts
before, this is basically a
modified version of the
quickstarts that we've been
showing off in some of the
earlier Google Developer
Live sessions.
They are also up
on the website.
And what I did, I just went
through that application and
changed the OAuth mechanism
to use Service Accounts.
So there's a couple things
I want to point out
for how this works.
These first couple lines up
here-- basically just the
information that we need in
order to have our app
authorize itself.
We have the service
account ID.
This is the email address
that is generated for
that service account.
You'll notice, if you go back
over to the API console, we
actually have two different
client IDs.
You have a client ID and
an email address.
Typically with OAuth 2.0, we're
using the client ID in
the various OAuth APIs to
identify our client.
In the case of the assertion
profile with Service Accounts,
we actually want to use the
email address instead.
So go over here.
We have our key file--
this is one that we
just downloaded earlier.
Again, it's a PKCS12 file, and
we also have the secret to
unlock the private key-- in this
case just not a secret.
The rest of this is actually
follows very similar to how
OAuth works in general.
We initialize the client.
We have the API we want to
discover-- in this case,
Google Drive.
But instead of going through
the redirects that we would
normally do for OAuth or normal
three-legged OAuth, We
actually just create
[? a new motor ?] key file,
create our [? asserter ?]
with our service account ID, the
scopes that we want, and
our private key.
And then we can make
an assertion.
That is very similar to what
would happen when in normal
OAuth where you get a code from
the user and you would
exchange that for
an access token.
In this case, we're just
exchanging the assertion for
an access token that we can
use in our application.
Once we have that set up, we
have an authorized client, and
we can just do an upload
as normal.
So we can actually go and try
this, and what we'll see here
is everything worked fine.
We uploaded the file, and
we have the metadata.
And the one thing I want
to point is the owning
user for this file.
And we can see here is our
service account-- our
application-- basically is
acting as a user and it owns
the content that we created.
So we can use those.
We can create as many
files as we want up
to our quota limits.
One of the limitations, though,
with this approach is,
there currently isn't a way
where you can actually buy
more storage quota for
your service account.
In terms of practical usage,
there are limits, but you can
still do some very interesting
things with Service Accounts.
The other case I
want to demo--
and first, I'm going to
switch over to here--
is this mode of user
impersonation.
And this is just our Google
Apps control panel.
We just have one of our test
domains here, [? Apps ?]
[? Rocks. ?]
And underneath Advanced Tools,
there's this link down here
for Manage Third-party
OAuth Client Access.
You can click here.
And I actually already created
this earlier, but here's where
we would do the delegation
for--
or basically to authorize our
application to impersonate
users on this domain.
So basically what you do is
you take the client ID--
this is the actual client ID for
the service account, not
the email address--
list the scopes.
And then you authorize.
Now what we can do is we can
go back into this file.
And now I'm just going to add
my email address here.
So when I authorize, instead
of authorizing on behalf of
the application, I want to
authorize on behalf of the
user for that domain.
I can go back in.
You can rerun this.
And what we'll see is now
the file is owned by me.
So even though it's basically
the same mechanism by virtue
of the fact that I have at the
domain level authorized this
particular application to act on
behalf of any of my users,
I can now easily switch.
This is really useful if you're
building Administrative
Tools, you're a domain
administrator, you want to do
auditing of docs usage or
reporting or just moving files
between users in a
programmatic way.
Obviously, it can be very
difficult to have lots of
different users come and
authorize your application.
This just allows you as a
privileged administrator to
create applications that can do
things across your domain
very easily.
If you were to try this and say,
let's change this to my
Google [? account, ?]
this will fail because this
application isn't allowed to
assert users on that domain.
So, pretty easy to use.
There is one other case for
Service Accounts that I want
to mention.
It's not something that is
currently supported, but this
is our App Engine robot
accounts which uses a
functionality very similar
to the Service Accounts
that we just saw.
But for various technical
reasons it is not yet fully
supported with the Drive API.
It is something that we're aware
of and looking to fix.
But if you do you want to use
service account functionality
on App Engine, particularly
with the Drive API, you do
need to do a service account
created through our APIs
console, as opposed to using
the built-in robot account
functionality that comes
with App Engine.
Again, something we're aware
of and looking to fix.
But there are workarounds
for the time being.
So that is Service Accounts.
Again, you can find this
functionality in most of our
client libraries.
It's generally pretty
easy to use--
particularly useful for domain
administrators that want to be
able to manage Google Drive on
behalf of their users, without
having to build a full-fledged
web application, and have to
go through the complexities
of requiring each user to
authorize themselves.
So that is all for today.
Look forward to seeing everyone
on Thursday at our
next session.
I don't know if we have a topic
yet, but once we have
that, we'll make sure that it is
announced and available on
developers.google.com/live.
And you can also find us on
Google+ and Stack Overflow.
Great, thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]